la décision va plaire aux 260 milles
québécoises qui ont signé cette pétition
québec facilite l'accès aux hormones bio
identique ces médicaments qu'on prescrit
pour soulager les problèmes causés par
la ménopause c'est une grande victoire
c'est un très grand pas dans
l'accessibilité pour les femmes qui en
font le soir
[Musique]
la docteure demers qui a participé à la
série documentaire l'auto meinau de
véronique cloutier estime que ce type de
traitement hormonal a beaucoup à offrir
aux femmes ménopausées sait comment les
études c'est que plus les femmes
à la ménopause et plus ça ne prenne mon
temps plus de respect ans de vie est
augmentée et qualité de vie et les
hormones bio identiques comme
l'estradiol 17b angèle et la
progestérone micronisée coûter cher le
ministère de la santé a négocié une
réduction de prix avec les entreprises
qui les produisent désormais ces
produits seront remboursés des gens
crient 40 dollars et y ait 70 80 dollars
par mois pour une des deux hormones
seulement donc je pense que ça vaut
l'utilisation de l'hormonothérapie
conventionnelle à baisser radicalement
après la publication lienne vingtaine
d'années d'études qui faisait état
d'effets secondaires importants sur la
santé des femmes la docteure des hôtels
constat que la nouvelle génération
d'hormones dit biot identique et plus
sécuritaire et que les médecins doivent
en tenir compte des médecins on doit
remettre les pendules à la
formation d'éducation que ce soit les
médecins la communauté des
professionnels de la santé ou les
patients ou la communauté en tarte l
faut commencer à remettre leur rôle des
hormones sur la bonne voie le ministère
de la santé produira bientôt un guide
destiné à favoriser une meilleure prise
en charge globale de la ménopause il si
normand grondin radio canada montréal